vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non je garde des enfants
bonsoir bonsoir anne nounours je vois
que tu as envie de danser ce soir moi
pas trop j'ai toujours envie de danser
je ferai un excellent professeur de
danse
si je voulais mais mais oui pourquoi pas
je suis professeur de danse mon échelle
rires propos ben moubamba
bonsoir les enfants voulez-vous être
baiser là qu'est ce que tu vas nous je
suis un professeur de danse à votre lave
est prêt et moi je suis professeur
je suis prête attention en place pour le
quadrille roulement attention mesdames
mais attention messieurs
non c'est un quadrillage de madame pape
rhône elle de ce côté ci quand je dirais
que si on s'incline de roi quand je fais
réclame se relèvera attention surtout ne
nous trompons pas voyons comment nous un
peu écouté tous les deux voilà je dis
qu'ils nous saluons n'est maintenant
qu'à 2 le relevons marche lentement en
comptant les pas à deux jeunes en
rencontrons justin planifiait ne nous
inclinons un peu tous les deux
à
lolo et les machines et salue graciée
merci mademoiselle n'est pas de quoi
messier enfin une dernière révérence
gentil voilà notre cadre i way ball à
votre titre
et voici pour notre projet certes aime
tellement les fleurs non merci mme petit
si tous les élèves étaient aussi gentil
que vous
il y en aurait trop d'un professeur et
pour faire plaisir à notre professeur
nous allons ne nuit mes petits élèves à
demain j'éteins la lumière fait pour
[Musique]
j'espère que vous faites comme les
élèves de nounours mes petits amis
et que vous allez au lit sans vous faire
prier au trot que charbon de soi rue
quel enfant repusseau est bien en route
professeur nounours bonne nuit les
enfants fêtes de bourg heures
et vous
où
à
[Musique]